moscou va riposter aux mesures inamicale
annoncé par londres a prévenu ce matin
le kremlin le royaume uni a annoncé des
sanctions à l'encontre de personnes et
organisations accusés de violations des
droits humains et hier à londres a
publié une liste noire de 49 personnes
en ce sens 25 citoyens russes y figurent
ils sont accusés d'être impliqués dans
la mort de l'avocat sergueï magnitski
lors de sa détention
la décision prise par le gouvernement
britannique d'imposer des sanctions
contre un certain nombre d'officiels
russes en invoquant la mort de sergueï
magnitski qu en 2009 est le reflet du
statut autoproclamé du royaume uni comme
leader mondial en matière de politique
de sanctions toutes les questions
relatives aux circonstances de la mort
de monsieur magnétique ont trouvé leur
réponse il ya bien longtemps
la décision d'aujourd'hui a été de façon
évidente
conçu comme une opération de
communication et pourra en parler
direction moscou avec notre
correspondant antoine clairon c'est par
la voix du porte-parole yeux kremlin que
les autorités ont réagi
dimitri peskov a pris acte de ce nouveau
train de sanctions contre la russie et
s'est réservé le droit d'y riposter
nous ne pouvons que regretter ces
mesures inamicale bien sur un principe
de réciprocité sera appliquée ainsi que
certaines réponses dans la mesure où
cela irait dans les intérêts de la
fédération de russie
l'ambassade de russie à londres a quant
à elle dénoncé ces sanctions comme je
cite une volonté de faire pression sur
des états souverains
tout en soulignant l'indépendance du
pouvoir judiciaire en russie
alors cette liste noire comprend les
noms de 49 personnes dont 25 citoyens
russes suspecté d'être impliqué dans la
mort de sergueï magnitski ce juriste
mort dans sa cellule de prison à moscou
en 2009
ces personnes ne pourront donc pas se
rendre au royaume uni et leurs avoirs
dans le pays le cas échéant seront donc
gelé parmi ces personnes présentes sur
cette liste noire il y à des enquêteurs
des juges ou encore le président du
comité d'enquêté russe
ce n'est donc pas une bonne nouvelle
pour les relations russo britanniques
déjà plombée par la sphère skripal
ou encore par leur différend sur le
dossier ukrainien ou encore sur le
dossier syrien